[Music]
Nikki and Brie Bella made it a sister's
night out on Tuesday in LA at the WWE
fyc event your sis passed on the press
for good reason how are you supporting
her during this this time that's sort of
such a whirlwind and being like every
sister in the world
you're just the backbone for your sister
I'm there for her I think the thing that
my sister loves the most about being
with me is we could sit in a room have
our wine and not say anything so it's
just showing sport that way hey Donna
it's like on and off you know people are
sort of confused because we're watching
your season of total Bella's and one
thing is happening and then in the real
world that's happening can you update us
do you know are they together they not
together can you speak to it you know
they're working on it so and I think
that's one thing is I think sometimes
people think like okay it's a breakup so
they need to make a decision quick you
know but no like everyone you just work
on it they need time and so for me I
just want them both to be happy so
whatever it is together or not I just
want them to be happy I just want him to
be like lonely and I don't want him to
like regret not being indebted do you
feel torn at all because obviously this
is your sister but you're you're very
close with John too you know so like is
that hard for you I'm one of those they
work on themselves in the relationship I
love John love him you know he's like a
brother to me we text we talk and I love
my sisters so it's like siblings it's
like do your thing whatever John's just
such a good man you guys were such a
great couple
is it hard to rewatch the show like is
that weird to see the drama unfold again
oh of course I think it's hard for
everyone else to see because you've been
so connected to my sister and I for the
last five years so it is I cry I cried
Sunday night I'm sure I'll cry next
Sunday night but you know it's it's like
when it comes to her one year old little
girl birdie brie is all smiles it's
crazy because even though it's so
exhausting it's so fulfilling I love it
but every day she's doing something
different and I'm just like oh my gosh
please don't stop doing this but
the next day she does something cuter so
I love it Brie's got a big career a
happy marriage and an adorable daughter
the icing on the cake the possibility of
an Emmy see everyone worked really hard
and to see it finally pay off here it's
just incredible I'm so happy for you
know not only the McMahons but all the
talent because every works really hard
[Music]
[Applause]